Today we have a very special guest joining us.
He stars in the hit series "Fear The Walking Dead"
and you can catch him in the upcoming Netflix film
"Ma Rainey's Black Bottom".
It is going to be epic.
And he also knows how to mix up a mean cocktail.
That's right.
"Bottomless Brunch" on AMC anyone?
Please welcome Colman Domingo!
Hello.
How are you, Drew?
Don't mind if I do, Colman,
thank you.
Same here, darling.
Oh my gosh,
I'm so excited that you're here on the show.
You have so many fans here and a wonderful career.
And fun fact,
you were given or nominated for a Barrymore Award.
Yes, I was actually.
Yeah, yes, your namesake.
So we're already connected, my friend,
we've been connected for many years and you have no idea.
I was so excited about that detail.
And by the way, they're all alcoholics so this is perfect.
(Colman laughing)
Of course, cheers.
So this is just apropos, cheers.
I decided to make a Black Manhattan
which is actually a Manhattan with bourbon and bitters,
but you swap out the Sweet Vermouth with Amaro,
which is a Italian digestif.
It's good for the belly but it's herbal
and it's really warm and cozy
and makes you feel like a nice fall blanket.
Anything like Jagermeister?
Exactly. (laughing)
Ooh, the cinnamon.
(inhales) Oh my, wait,
what is on the rim of the glass?
There's a little cinnamon there, right?
Oh gosh, it's so aromatic.
Isn't it (laughing) love it.
It's just beautiful.
Now you started doing "Bottomless Brunch" on AMC
which is such a fun show.
And by the way, gardening goals.
Oh my God.
Well, you know the pandemic had me in the garden.
I was doing things I'd never done before.
I was digging, trying to grow things.
And then I was,
I wanted to create a show
which was bringing people together,
very similar to your show.
Just like,
I think we're people who like to bring people together
and spread some joy and light in the world.
So that's what "Bottomless Brunch at Colman's" is all about.
It's on AMC, it's streaming now on AMC.com
and it's just fun.
I bring people together like Common
and Yahya Abdul-Mateen and Niecy Nash,
Julia Styles, you name it.
You never know who's gonna show up.
It's so great,
and also can you please
tell us about "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom" because,
sorry, is that the title?
Okay, great.
That's it.
All of a sudden I panicked.
I've been watching the trailers.
This is a very, very important film.
It's Chadwick Boseman's last film.
It's Viola Davis, it's directed by George C. Wolfe.
It is gonna come out to Netflix in the end of December.
Can you tell us about it?
Absolutely, "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom" is,
it takes place on one hot afternoon with jazz musicians.
Ma Rainey's recording
in this session up in Chicago in 1920s.
And it's basically just trying to get through the day.
And it's a wrestle about ideologies,
about what it is to be black in America,
what it is to be an artist.
It's passionate,
it really tells a story of Ma Rainey
who was one of the first openly gay jazz musicians,
and her band.
Chad Boseman and I,
we play members of the band, I'm the band leader,
and we wrestle.
Literally, we wrestle.
We wrestle, we fight,
we try to find a new way of living.
And it's an August Wilson play who did "Fences",
it's produced by Denzel Washington.
I'm very excited for this.
Colman, this went by so fast.
I can't thank you enough for being here.
You are such a privilege to hang out with, drink with,
and you deserve all the awards in the world.
Thank you so much.
We'll be looking out for your important new film
and celebrating you with bottomless brunches
and "Fear The Walking Dead" on AMC.
Thank you, Colman.
Thank you, Drew.
Take care, good to see you.
Cheers to you!
(upbeat music)